[Musique]
gérard un metteur en scène m'a dit un
jour gérard philipe vient de me refuser
de jouer dans mon film où je lui propose
un rôle de prêtre en me répondant non
car je ne crois pas en dieu
comment est-ce que vous choisissez
comment est-ce que vous refusez vos
rôles la question est pertinente
elles mêmes impertinente figurez-vous je
vais vous raconter mois une autre
anecdote il y avait une fois un
professeur au conservatoire très réputé
et qui interrogé une élève
cet élève lui disait madame madame je
veux je veux jouer un rôle c'est toute
ma vie et si je ne joue pas celui-là est
vite et bien je ne ferai pas de théâtre
jamais c'est une tragédie et c'est fed
mais seulement je ne sais pas si je
pourrai mais pourquoi si la professeur
madame madame je n'ai jamais eu de
relation et ses pas et je ne sais pas si
et madame latéraux et lui dit tu seras
tout trouvé dans ton coeur je crois donc
que si j'avais à interpréter le rôle
d'un partisan d'un partisan de dieu de
l'homme de la matière de l'esprit je
m'en référerai à ces quelques parcelles
qui forment la qualité d'une âme et qui
se retrouve dans toutes les âmes vous
avez tourné cette année deux films
oui les liaisons dangereuses et vous
venez de terminer la fièvre monte à elle
parle
oui qu'est-ce qui vous a plu dans la
façon de mettre en scène de vadim vadim
a pour les acteurs une attention
particulière et il est très agréable
d'entendre dire à vadim tous les défauts
que l'on peut avoir que l'on a acquis le
long des films que l'on a tourné
jusqu'ici qu'elles déploient toutes
sortes
ce sont ce qu'on appelle des défauts de
gestes de compensation par exemple est
de compensation par exemple si je ne me
reconnais pas soyez un bon donc j'aurai
raté par si la veille et bien ce genre
de gestes et de même que par exemple de
dodeliner de la tête pour affirmer la
conviction d'un des personnages affirmé
conviction ce sont des gestes que l'on
acquiert lorsque par exemple on a joué
trop souvent dans l'année au théâtre ou
dans un théâtre je veux dire dans un
théâtre où il y à 3000 places c'est à
dire que la phrase devant être entendus
à 67 m en même temps c'est le sentiment
lui-même qu'on laissait d'appuyer en
l'accentuant d'une de ces mouvements de
tête
détail évidemment que tout cela mais en
même temps c'est une aide précieuse car
on a un homme près de soi qui se penche
sur vous et vous aide à vous regarder
jouer bien gros plans ya trop de petits
détails non en gros plan il n'ya pas de
petits détails mais aussi en gros plan
je me contrôle moi même plus et on a
moins à me dire mais c'est dans les
plans généraux que on se laisserait
aller plus facilement
oui dans les mauvais aussi dans les
situer aussi dans les scènes qui se sont
eux aussi dans les scènes qui ne sont
pas parfaitement écrite il y à des
scènes dans les situations ne sont pas
solides
l'acteur se sent lâché et ils essaient
d'aider hauteur et de boucher les trous
parfois avec maladresse
[Musique]